So everybody, this is Dr. Kevin counters and I wanted to talk to you about hydrogen peroxide.
It's use in treatment of disease in particular cancer.
Why one would maybe choose to do it and why one would maybe not choose to do it and if
you're a patient of ours, you know already that I fall on the not choose to use it spectrum.
But I'm going to give you the pros and cons and just kind of make help you make your
own decision.
So hydrogen peroxide is H2O2 so it's different than water, it has two hydrogens and two oxygens.
Therefore it can react and I'm going to show you the way it can react to our body.
Now normally it's made in our body and in our body it acts as an intermediate metabolite.
It means it's made through the breakdown of super oxide ion, which is this red guy right here.
Super oxide ion can be extremely reactive and dangerous.
It goes on to form with the presence of nitric oxide.
It forms a peroxidite rate, which is this O and O, O negative.
And peroxidite rate is very dangerous in our body.
It can cause cancer, causes cell breakage, DNA breakage, all sorts of bad things that peroxidite rate can cause peroxidite rate is not supposed to stay in our body very long.
It's peroxidite rate has a very short half life.
And because of this enzyme, SOD, which you've heard me talk about with, when we talk about genetics, super oxide disc retace is a very important enzyme made by your super oxide disc retace genes.
And the purpose of it is to get rid of this super oxide ion so we don't form any of the peroxidite rate, which could be so damaging and cancer-causing.
So we want to get rid of this super oxide ion.
We do so through making super oxide disc retace.
Now in the process of making, getting rid of super oxide, super oxide disc retace converts super oxide in the presence of hydrogen to hydrogen peroxide.
So that's hydrogen peroxide right there.
And hydrogen peroxide is then further broken down quite quickly through cantalase and glutathione peroxidase to water.
So then we, that is dispelled through our urinary tract and we get rid of our water.
So our water is produced through partially, through the breakdown of hydrogen peroxide through the use of another enzyme, cantalase.
And that always comes back through getting rid of super oxide ions and reactive oxygen species.
Now reactive oxygen species are a problem in our body because that contributes to oxidative stress.
So think of oxidative stresses like your metal on your car rusting.
That's exactly what's taking place.
The higher it is reacting with oxygen and causing rust formation.
That's the breakdown. That's oxidation of that iron.
So that's what's taking place in our body and that can damage cells.
That can be a cancer cause or in itself.
And when we talk about your genes, we look at your super oxide genes, we look at all your iron genes too.
Because in the presence of iron, super oxide can go down this pathway and form this bad guy, which is a hydroxyl free radical.
Hydroxyl free radicals can damage cells, can be cancer causers in themselves as well.
So we don't want hydroxyl free radicals.
We don't want, you know, that's where excess iron can be a problem.
And we look at genes that can cause that.
And we don't want super oxide ions either.
So the necessary need for enzymes in our body, super oxide dispatase is an enzyme cannellase and glutathione peroxidase are enzymes.
They help break down bad guys in our body so they don't stay in our body long.
Now why would we have these bad guys anyhow?
Well, I said they are intermediate metabolites.
So it's as your body's breaking down other things to get rid of it.
It breaks down this into these intermediate products that aren't supposed to stay in our body long.
But in truth, they do serve a purpose.
We need a balance that you heard me say in many other times that it's not, there's not just good guys and bad guys always.
Yes, in excess, these things are bad guys.
It's reactive oxidative species, it reacts of nitrogen species can be really bad guys and can be the cause of cancer and other diseases in our body, including aging and degenerative neurological diseases, et cetera.
But it's always in balance.
They serve a purpose for a very short time too, because they could help kill pathogens in our body.
So they do serve a purpose.
We'll talk about that.
Here's what we look at the genetic piece.
You're super oxide genes create super oxide disc retace and breakdown super oxide into hydrogen peroxide that with the glutathione peroxidase of the caneles break it down into water, all preventing this bad guy from forming the peroxid nitrate.
That is so damaging to ourselves.
So when we understand why it's there as an intermediate metabolite that it does serve a purpose, it can help oxidize pathogens.
We don't want to oxidize our cells, because we oxidize our cells, our cells die.
Our cells could go through mutations if it gets inside the cell, which hydrogen peroxide does readily cross the cell membrane.
Proxy nitrate tends not to cross the cell membrane, damage the cell membrane, which can lead to cancer.
Hydrogen peroxide can cross the cell membrane, which can be good and bad.
Inside the cell, it can help oxidize pathogens and kill pathogens.
So pathogens like a bacteria or a virus or something like that.
But it can also damage the DNA.
There's much research that excess oxidative damage due to excess hydrogen peroxide, and most of the studies are based upon diseases that cause a decrease in super oxide disc retace.
So there are some animals that you could actually eliminate the gene super oxide disc retace and research so that you can study what happens to an organism when they don't have any super oxide disc retace meeting that they have excess hydrogen peroxide.
So what does excess hydrogen peroxide do to our body?
If it gets into the cell, it could cause DNA breakage, and therefore it could cause cancer.
It could cause protein damage to proteins, lipid peroxidation, which is very damaging to your cell membranes.
So it just damages, ruins your cell membranes, ruins your proteins, can damage other enzymes and can cause DNA breakage, which could lead to a whole mess of stuff going on, including cancer.
So excess hydrogen peroxide is not good.
It can lead some to help clear pathogens, but excess is not good. That's why it's all about balance.
So if we say, we're going to use this as a therapy, and we're going to flood our body with IV hydrogen peroxide, could that be very damaging to healthy cells?
The answer is yes, it could be very damaging to healthy cells, and that's where we do have to be very careful with its use.
So why would you use it? Why would you use hydrogen peroxide?
Well, 3% hydrogen peroxide can be a wonderful topical antiseptic. It can kill bacteria just through the mechanisms that I just explained.
The bacteria tend to be acidic, and it will oxidate bacteria or reacts with them. That's the foaming action that you see if you pour it on a wound, and you see it bubble up a little bit.
That's because hydrogen peroxide is breaking down into oxygen and water through the actin on the acidic bacteria, thereby oxidizing the bacteria, killing the bacteria.
So good things. Yes, so using hydro peroxide as a topical can be beneficial. External ear infections, a little bit hydro peroxide can be super beneficial.
When you start talking about taking hydro peroxide, orally, people are using that as higher concentration, and what you're using as a topical antiseptic is the 3% hydro peroxide.
If people are taking it orally, they're using a food grade, 35% hydro peroxide, and they're only taking a couple drops of it.
So is it excess? Well, I don't know. So this is where we have to make that decision. What will it do? It can affect healthy cells, that affect it will affect healthy cells in excess, and will increase reactive oxygen species with all its negative effects.
So we can keep that in mind. So again, why would we use it? Well, if they use it orally, how effective is hydrogen peroxide orally? Think about that.
So you have superoxide disretace enzymes, hopefully in your body, and they're going to break that down.
Now, will it damage the stomach lighting? Will it damage the gut lighting before it gets broken down? Quite possibly.
Where do you see a benefit of using oral hydrogen peroxide therapy with cancer? Well, if a person has stomach cancer, they have duodenal cancer.
They have esophageal cancer. Think about that from a physiological standpoint, could the hydrogen peroxide get right to that cancer and help kill those cancer cells? Quite possibly.
If a person has breast cancer and they're taking it orally, what's the chance of it getting absorbed, getting circulated through the bloodstream, getting to that breast cancer site and effectively affecting those breast cancer cells?
Why would it be attracted to those breast cancer cells so far away from the swallowing it down into your stomach? It has to go a long way to get to those breast cancer cells.
Just think about that. Would it damage other cells much more readily along the way? There's no physiological proof in any writing that is hydro peroxide is attracted to a cancer cell.
So to get it to the cancer cell, that is the tricky part. Now, I know there are some places in Europe that may be injecting a small amount of hydrogen peroxide.
I know there's other places in Mexico or Europe that are using IV hydrogen peroxide. Is it safe? I don't know. I throw a big red flag up there because the risk to endothelial cells is so great.
Oxidative stress to endothelial cells is really the cause of heart disease. So boy, I would personally, I wouldn't use it in an IV form.
Even in, you know, in serious cancer, I still wouldn't. And what it wouldn't do to my gut lining.
Yeah, if I had a syphagel cancer, if I had a stutter cancer, I'd certainly seriously consider using it because you have just physiologically the ability to get it right at the cancer.
To use it topically on a cancer that's growing out of the breast or something like that. Yes, it's possible. We had patients use that. It could be very painful.
Just think about that. Those, these are just possibilities we're just throwing out.
And there's other studies that show that hydrogen peroxide can actually make cancer worse.
And this goes to, so let's take a step back a little bit.
Higher peroxide is an oxidizing agent. You realize that chemotherapies work as oxidizing agents to strong oxidizing agents are poisons.
That's what a poison is. It's a strong oxidizing agent. So if we could get hydrogen peroxide right to the cancer, would we effectively kill the cancer in strong enough concentrations? The answer is quite possibly.
But the same thing with chemotherapy, if we could get chemotherapy right to the cancer, will we help kill the cancer in strong enough concentrations? The answer is quite possibly.
But the truth also is is that chemotherapy on a cancer can actually make the cancer grow. And there are a percentage of all cancer patients that are doing chemotherapy, a percentage, the chemotherapy actually works, a percentage, the chemotherapy actually makes the patient worse.
It's the same thing with hydrogen peroxide. And this is the mechanism of action through this that was published through this study, showing that hydrogen peroxide can actually make a cancer worse.
Here's the brief of this study, hydrogen peroxide and reactive oxygen species production through hydrogen peroxide, which I outlined in the tumor micro environment, meaning right at the tumor site, fuels that anabolic growth of cancer cells.
In a true chemotherapy, we could substitute chemotherapy, that word chemotherapy for hydrogen peroxide here too.
So this doesn't always happen, but in this study, they showed the mechanism of action and how that can happen. It fuels the anabolic growth of cancer cells.
Recently, we proposed a new mechanism for understanding the Warburg effect. We've explained the Warburg effect in other videos in tumor metabolism. In this new paradigm, cancer cells induce oxidative stress in neighboring cancer associated fiber blasts.
Then oxidative stress in cancer associated fiber blasts triggers the activation of two main transcriptions factors and have kept capabata and hif1a that we've spoken about these in other videos.
NF capabata is a hyperinflammatory response to a disorder and hif1a pushes that pathway of after glycolysis towards an etabolic production of energy. That's what problem with cancer is that's why we look at the hif genes when we look at your cancer genes.
This leads to the onset of inflammation, and I would say hyperinflammation at the site, autophagy in aerobic glycolysis, meaning the cancer is feeding down off of aerobic glycolysis, which is really what we're going to see in a second.
The reverse Warburg effect, which is actually increase metabolic rate of the cancer greatly in the tumor micro environment, this type of stromal metabolism then produces high energy nutrients, meaning you are going to kick out ATP.
You are going to push cancer into a pathway that even fuels it even greater, as well as which will increase nutrients lactate, ketones and glutamate, as well as recycled chemical building blocks to literally feed cancer cells.
These nutrients stimulate mitochondrial biogenesis and adjacent cancer cells, meaning growing more cancer cells.
In addition, oxidative stress and reactive oxidative oxidizing species, produced in cancer associated fiber, fiber blasts has a bystander effect on adjacent cancer cells leading to DNA damage, to know what instability etc etc etc.
This is what's been called the reverse Warburg effect that can actually make the cancer grow even quicker, and that's why sometimes chemotherapy has the reverse effect of what they want.
Person does chemotherapy and the chemotherapy didn't work, not only did the chemotherapy, the reason why they're saying the chemotherapy didn't work is because the cancer continued to grow.
And most likely if the person didn't do any chemotherapy, it would have grown at a much smaller rate than if they did chemotherapy.
Now again, this is not at all patients, sometimes chemotherapy as well as sometimes doing direct hydrogen peroxide therapy can actually help kill the cancer cell because it's in high enough concentration that it's that it's going to actually cause the oxidative stress and damage to the cell beyond its ability to survive.
They're by killing the cell causing cell lysis, but it does carry with it the dangers of not causing cell lysis and actually feeling the cell to grow faster.
So the pros and cons, I know there's a multiple a lot of things to say, shouldn't we use it pros and cons if you have your oxide, this is why I fall on the cons side, I think there's too much danger, the research suggests that it might not be the best therapy.
We use more anti oxidizing agents in our therapy and our natural approach.
And this is again why so you understand oxidation versus anti oxidation, this is why when you do chemotherapy your college doesn't want you to use a lot of anti oxidizing supplements because can't because chemotherapy is a highly oxidative process, it's a poisonous process.
But we do risk even with chemotherapy this same process taking place and the cancer actually going through a reverse warberg effect and actually fueling the cancer.
That's why my opinion, we don't want to use chemotherapy as our first line of defense, we want to use that other things are working.
And that's where I would say that if everything is going south, this is where you'd pull hydrogen peroxide possibly out of your basket to see if we want to utilize that or attempt to utilize that to help kill the cancer if everything else is not working.
Okay, so that gives you roughly 20 minutes of solid information that you might have to listen to a couple times.
Bottom line is, I don't suggest using hydro peroxide unless it's a last ditch effort and everything else is failed.
Because it works basically the same way as chemotherapy and you could have pros and cons to it.
Thank you very much, Dr. Kevin Cutters.
For more information, cuttersclinic.com.
We have over 400 videos on our YouTube channel, subscribe and catch any new ones we have coming.
Thank you much.